you know Ellen it's one of the simplest
safety rules we teach our children don't
open the door for strangers and yet
despite one family's best attempts it
happened this weekend now as police
investigate we sat down with the child's
father who wants others to learn from
his family's own traumatic experience
around 3 30 Saturday afternoon security
camera footage captured this pair
walking up the stairs to a home in North
York and opening the screen door
the woman Knocks
and knocks again after a couple failed
attempts of getting my son's attention
who happened who happens to be 13 years
of age sure enough my son answered the
door he was Home Alone
the woman can be heard asking if the
boy's mother is home suggesting she told
her to come the video appears to show a
sharp tool in the man's hand with his
son at home alone the homeowner received
a notification on an app on his phone
connected to the home security system he
saw two people on his doorstep and then
he watched as they went inside we agreed
to protect his identity due to safety
concerns I'm watching this and I was
horrified of what was happening and what
was taking place how cunning they are
and my wife was at the other end seeing
this and she was horrified trying to
contact my son they called 9-1-1 and
rushed home meantime Phil the couple was
up to no good their sons stayed calm and
told them his mother was in the basement
and father was in the backyard it's live
horror my son was being taken like
hostage in his own home soon after he
says they took a laptop computer and
fled how's he doing he's traumatized
besides installing an outdoor security
camera the father hopes other families
reinforce this one simple lesson with
their children just didn't know you know
not to open the door and we've told him
countless times but don't answer the way
there's no need to answer the door
now the homeowner told us there have
been break-ins in the area and the video
captured by his security camera Saturday
is so clear he hopes it will help police
as they investigate Alan just a
terrifying incident for the child and as
you can imagine frightening for the
parents who watched part of it unfold
live on their cell phones absolutely
terrifying for that family thank you
Karen